how you show up matters
having a powerful presence can make or
break your transactions your
relationships and your career
hello i'm matt abrahams and i teach
strategic communication at stanford
graduate school of business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
today i'm really excited to be joined by
jeff pfeffer who is a professor of
organizational behavior at stanford's
gsb
jeff's research focuses on the effects
of work environments on health and
well-being as well as power and
leadership in organizations
he teaches the super popular course the
paths to power
and he is the author of many books
including dying for a paycheck and power
why some people have it and others don't
welcome jeff thanks for being here
well matt thank you for having me on
your show
great i'm super excited to get started
so my first question is how do you
define power and status and why do you
think your class that covers these
topics is so popular
i define power is the ability it's the
ability to get things done
against opposition
uh and oftentimes of course as we try to
make things happen we find that not
everybody agrees with us
and i think the class is popular because
i have this very bad habit of teaching
people and actually telling the truth
and so therefore i think my students
both online and offline and everybody i
talk to actually appreciates knowing how
to get things done in a world in which
oftentimes that's difficult and they and
they like hearing the truth as i like to
say jack nicholson um was actually wrong
uh people do want to hear the truth
that's one of my favorite movies for
sure and and i i chuckled when you said
you know often those in power can't get
things done as as the father of two
teenagers uh that is certainly true
um
it's joining companies as well yes yes
yes uh for my next few questions i want
to get very tactical and specific if you
don't mind so
are there specific non-verbal behaviors
or body language if you will that we can
employ to be seen as more powerful and
having higher status are there things we
should avoid doing as well
absolutely and in fact i'm sure this is
what you teach in your class
um they're
we give away our power by tilting our
heads we give away our power by looking
down we give away our power particularly
when we hunch over
and we constrict our our body in in on
itself uh if you want to see an example
of this uh watch tony hayward testifying
in the bp hearings where he looks
they're the the no gestures and he's
really hunched in and reading a script
um and so reading or reading a statement
and so all those things i think give
away power and by on the contrary uh you
have power to the extent that you look
people in the eye you have power to the
extent that you stand up to your full
height whatever that is you have power
to the extent that you use expansive
uh you take an expansive posture
you spread out you take up more space
and you certainly have power to the
extent that you use forceful gestures
and anybody who's ever watched somebody
speak or watch the movie understands
what a forceful gesture is as opposed to
a one that isn't
excellent so you're right in the classes
i teach we talk about being big balanced
and still to demonstrate presence and it
sounds like you're echoing that advice
absolutely let's switch from non-verbal
to verbal are there specific verbal
behaviors we can employ to be seen as
more powerful or having higher status
and are there things that we should
avoid saying
so
one of the ways in which you convey
power is
by being loud one of the ways in which
you convey power is by being modestly or
moderately impolite in interrupting
other people and by by contrast one way
in which you um don't give away your
power if you refuse to yourself be
interrupted
so so that's
that's one set of things and then
there's powerful language you you want
to use simple
language forceful language vivid
language vivid words and and keep it
keep it simple and direct
very very direct and simple in your
answer thank you i'm curious your
thoughts because i deal a lot with this
in the work that i do around filler
words and words of hesitation like kind
of and sort of do you have insights on
on that and how that affects how people
perceive us
you don't want to use filler words and
you don't want to use to the extent
possible um's or oz or anything else
like that you want to be you want to
speak as if
even though it's not rehearsed it's been
completely rehearsed and you want to not
have any filler words whatsoever
okay so fluency is is important for sure
absolutely
let's move away from verbal and
nonverbal behavior and i'm curious if
you have any thoughts on how emotion
relates to power and status are there
certain emotions we may want to display
while avoiding others
absolutely but but in general i think we
want to see people come across strong
anger is a much stronger emotion than
sadness or then uh you know any kind of
remorse or or or hesitation or whatever
so anger is a very strong emotion and i
i have found uh in dealing with the
various people that i deal with and
particularly the institutions that i
deal with many of which have
done a very good job of not providing
good customer service and your
audience can figure out who they are but
oftentimes displaying anger gets much
more results than you know than begging
or you know cajoling or pleading or you
know throwing yourself on the mercy of
whoever the particular organization
happens to be
you should you should use strong
emotions and anger and forcefulness is
much stronger than pleading or
apology or something like that
so there are certain situations for sure
where where anger is appropriate uh
there are others where it is not is is
something just like being very
passionate in in convicted in your your
belief or what you're saying does that
help as well
absolutely there's no question that that
to the extent that you are excited i
mean we know that emotions are
contagious um you walk down an airline
corridor to the extent that anybody
walks on an airline corridor
smile at people they smile back if you
frown
they'll frown
so we know that they've been studies
emotions are contagious and that means
energy is contagious passion is
contagious conviction is contagious
so yes you want to you want to be
passionate you want to be energetic you
want to have conviction about what
you're talking about confidence is
contagious you want to display
confidence both in words and in body
language and in the languages you use
you want to say i think there may be
some chance that our new venture might
succeed you want to say
we are going to succeed and there's no
question about it
great example i i can't tell you the
number of entrepreneurs i work with who
have such hedging language in what they
say
yet they are completely
involved and engaged in what they're
saying and passionate about it it
strikes me jeff that the the what you
just talked about of in terms of strong
emotions
that actually leads to
some of the things you discussed with
non-verbal and verbal behavior when we
are passionate about something or angry
about something we gesture broadly we're
more expressive in our voice the
language choice we use
so the emotion can actually drive some
of that nonverbal and verbal behavior
you mentioned
no that's exactly correct i mean to the
extent that you're passionate um and
convicted and uh and confident you're
more likely to speak in a louder voice
right right right
so you were very kind uh to give me a
sneak peek at your upcoming book and i'm
very excited to for that to come out in
it you talk about how our faces convey a
lot of useful information regarding our
power and status
given that we are spending a lot of time
communicating virtually where only our
faces show up what advice would you give
to people who want to be perceived as
competent and higher status when all we
see is a video representation of our
faces
well i think in the picture i'm looking
at of you now i think is a fabulous
example of this why thank you so you
practice what you teach um i think
people
even prior to the pandemic but certainly
since the pandemic have gotten way too
sloppy about how they dress and how they
show up and you know i mean maybe
mark zuckerberg can get away with a
hoodie i think for most people you can't
i think you should you should look
you sh you should dress and show up
as how you want people to perceive you
so first and foremost uh my the the
folks behind my style if i have any will
be very pleased my wife and my two kids
are going to be very thankful because i
i could not do anything so thank you for
noticing that and then second it really
sounds like just like we need to be
thinking about what we say in our
messages and how we structure them for
presence and power we also need to think
about how we show up and
some of the literature that i'm familiar
with suggests that how you frame
yourself matters you should take up half
the screen and not sitting too far away
we read a lot on people's faces and if i
can't see your face because you're too
far away or you're sitting in the dark
that actually makes you look more
suspicious less powerful so it's not
only how you dress and how you look as
you mentioned it's also how you frame
yourself also matters
let me ask you this question
what would you suggest
that someone who ado who is in a lower
status or power position who wants to
make sure someone in a higher status or
power position pays attention to their
communication for example a line
employee talking to his or her boss or
even me talking to our deans
uh i i think you need to uh think hard
about what you're going to say
and you want to make it concise and you
want to
lead with the most powerful part of your
message and the part of the message you
want them to pay the most attention to
because people have always had short
attention spans and the attention spans
have gone down i think you want to do
pretty much what i've just what we've
been talking about you want to speak
directly you want to communicate
directly you want to show up if you're
communicating with them in person in a
way that shows um that that you're
someone to be taken seriously um and and
you know in in how you dress and how you
hold yourself and how you convey
yourself to both your body language and
your spoken language so i you know i
think you would do all the things that
we've talked about regardless of who
you're talking to if you want your
message to be heard
excellent advice i i often add in these
situations to somehow link what you're
saying to something of value to them can
be helpful not only to demonstrate that
you understand what's important for them
but that you've taken the time to make
your message relevant and tailored it is
yes well if you want to tailor your
message i mean you should always as we
understand
you should begin of course by uh
by by flattering them and
the research suggests that there is no
amount of flattery that it's too much so
you want to tell them how how much you
admire what they've done and how much
you respect uh their abilities and all
this other stuff um if you want to if
you want them to take you seriously you
want to show them how much you admire
them and how much you respect them and
how happy you are to be in their
presence
well jeff that is probably the best
answer i've ever had on this podcast and
i so admire you taking the time to
actually address that answer to us
i'm curious if you have upon reflecting
on your research and and your experience
any last bits of advice around how to
have a powerful high status presence
that you'd like to share
well i think you know when i have uh
bill that uh english and susie damolado
who are co-founders and of the san
francisco playhouse come and teach my
session on acting with power they give
the students i think fabulous advice
which i will pass on on their behalf
to your listeners and that is
to warm up
so they talk about getting your voice
warmed up getting your body warmed up
obviously not in public uh you know
maybe you know shaking yourself out or
you know shaking your body or
going mama my mom to warm up your voice
so that when you are you know i mean you
can see actors and actresses do this
before they go on stage or before they
go to get filmed but you should warm up
in advance of everything you do and one
of the things you should do as part of
the warm-up process is calm yourself
down so that so that you're not you
don't show up in a nervous fashion and
you show up basically ready to go i mean
if i said to you you know matt you're
going to go play football before
particularly given our ages but even
before before you went on the football
field you would probably do some
stretches and some exercises to warm up
and the same advice holds for speech
and and communication you want to warm
up so that when you
enter the moment you are as relaxed
and as
you know ready to go as you can be
if i were playing football jeff i would
sign my will and power of attorney and
then i would warm up but
uh you are uh you're exactly right in
terms of of taking time to warm up so
many people are so focused on what
they're saying they don't take time to
actually prepare their bodies their
minds their voice for actually saying it
and we often are so busy in rushing
around that we don't give ourselves even
time to prepare the content as best we
could so that's wonderful advice to to
really build into the process a time to
warm up and the great thing about being
virtual
is
nobody needs to see it until you turn
your camera on and unmute your mic you
can do some of that warming up so there
are actually some advantages i think to
being virtual
now before we end
i'd like to ask you the same three
questions i ask everyone who joins me
are you up for that
i'm up for that okay he says hesitantly
i'm not sure i have a choice but sure of
course
yes i have the power in this situation
uh if you were to capture the best
communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title
what would it be
warm up don't be nervous
i like it
uh very very concise
and uh i think with the exception of one
word there all were one syllable words
warm up don't be nervous and we have
spent time on this podcast definitely
talking about anxiety management so
those who are still nervous speaking i
encourage you to listen in on those
episodes
number two jeff who is a communicator
that you admire and why
um
i'm gonna back up and ask you to define
admire
so most people take this question to
mean somebody that they respect somebody
that they feel demonstrates
communication skills that are worthy of
others to consider and and use does that
help
yeah that helps i'm going to give you
two answers okay um you know i think i
think barack obama is a fabulous
communicator but i also think donald
trump is an extremely effective
communicator and i think people can
learn a lot by watching what he does and
how he
manages an audience and how he responds
and feeds off the audience and how he
plays into the audience and how what you
say
doesn't
matter as much is how you say it and
there's a lot of research that suggests
that
yeah absolutely and a lot of people have
looked at his speaking style and
identified things that we can all learn
from
so number three the final question
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe
a successful communication i didn't hear
the last word recipe imagine you're a
cook in a kitchen putting together a
successful communication dish what are
the first three ingredients
simplicity
um simplicity for sure
[Music]
forcefulness
and
the third ingredient simplicity
forcefulness
and uh and volume
interesting
tell me a little bit more about
forcefulness i think we get simplicity
and i think volume makes sense but what
do you mean by forcefulness forcefulness
means you know uh
being speaking with conviction okay
which which means
not only your voice and not only the
loudness of your voice but you know
acting
acting as if you mean what you say
um you know and you know this is old
saying which i think has been taken very
badly out of context and which you know
i think has been misused in some sense
which is fake it till you make it um i
think the real
the real saying is fake it until you
become it if you say something often
enough and with enough conviction over
time you may not convince any other
human beings but you will certainly
convince yourself and for you to be able
to convince anybody else of something
you have to believe what's coming out of
your mouth
that's a great way of explaining
forcefulness thank you
and thank you jeff for taking time to be
with us today
all of us are truly appreciative of the
detailed specific advice and guidance
that you have provided and i expect that
all of us will be sitting up a little
straighter
talking a little louder being a little
forceful so that we too can have a
strong presence that's powerful and high
in status thanks so much jeff
pleasure being with you
thank you for listening to think fast
talk smart the podcast a production of
stanford graduate school of business to
learn more go to gsb.stanford.edu
please download other episodes wherever
you find your podcasts